how do you get this song all about that
bass I wrote that with Kevin Kadish we
talked about a childhood and I said I
grew up chubby and he was like me too
and I was like oh my god bond he said I
have this title all bass no treble and I
can't figure out how to make it work and
I looked down and was like all bass no
treble
so you said oh well bass my ass yeah and
then and and the boobs were the trouble
I was like I really have big boobs
whatever we did that la weed calls you
to his office right he wants to meet you
you walk in with a ukulele because I was
in LA for a songwriting trip and I
usually have some kind of instrument in
that week I was lazy so I brought the
little one you did it on the ukulele
yeah cuz that's all I had and I'm
nervous when he walked in the room oh
god yeah our Vegas to that day if you
would Megan
hey yeah it's pretty clear I ain't no
size two but I can't shake it shake it
like I'm supposed to do cuz I got that
boom boom that all the boys chase
alright junkie no - I places I sleep
magazines working that Photoshop we know
that [ __ ] ain't we'll come on I'll make
it stop if you got beauty beauty just
raise them up every inch of you is
perfect from the bottom to the top yeah
my mama she told me don't worry about
your size now don't worry baby cuz boys
like a little more booty to hold a night
that booty booty you know I won't be no
stick figure silicone Barbie doll no no
no and so if that's what you're into go
ahead and blow
because you know I'm all about that bass
bout that bass no treble I'm all about
that bass bout that bass no treble I'm
all about that bass bout that bass no
treble I'm all about that bass bout that
bass
bring it back good it's out I'm Stanley
[ __ ] said well no I'm just playing on
though y'all think you're bad but I'm
here to tell you every inch of you is
perfect from the bottom to the top
my mama's you told me you don't worry by
your side no no baby baby boy cycle it
some more 52 Holden aye hey you know I
won't be no stick figure silicone Barbie
doll no no no so that's what you're into
go ahead and move along because you know
I'm all about that bass bout that bass
no treble I'm all about that bass bout
that bass no treble I'm all about that
bass bout that bass no treble I'm all
about that bass bout that bass we'll
know about that bass bout that bass
about that bass about that bass
I'm all about that bass bout that bass
that is beautiful no wonder LA resided
you know I was thinking about Robin why
work she's all about the treble Oh get
out of here
Centrum yeah you got a lot of trouble